well starting this weekend unemployment
claimants will have to prove
they're out there looking for work
previously the work search requirement
for benefits was waived through the
pandemic but that's going to change
joe mohler is live tonight to explain
the details joe
we know many businesses across the
valley are hiring we've done a number of
stories on it and just here in this
parking lot i saw a handful
of now hiring signs on the front doors
of these businesses well now dieter
wants claimants to show they are
applying
for our jobs out there and this will go
for both pua and regular ui claimants
i would like to go back to
my original job that i had at the
airport melissa taylor can't go back to
her job and now has to find a new one
she's keeping records of the job she's
applying for when you go on there you
like put in the date that you put in you
put the business where you put in then
you put the address
and you put how you did it
phone call in person she has been
keeping the information
for the work search requirement when she
files her weekly claims really deter is
just asking that you make an effort to
re-enter the job force
amber hanson runs a popular unemployment
assistance page on facebook
starting may 2nd all claimants will be
required to provide work search
information
if the ui site on a weekly basis when
they go on sundays to file their claim
when they get to a certain screen in
their claim it's just going to be like a
little table that's going to say like
who did you contact how many
applications did you put in what is that
person's contact information
the requirement was waived throughout
the pandemic for pua claimants who are
independent contractors or gig workers
this is all new like they're not really
the same as ui claimants who really kind
of had this standard form of inputting
you know i applied at xyz and this is
their contact information
and for the side it's more of a good
faith effort of saying
you know i'm ready to rejoin the
workforce whether it be by
advertising their services or networking
on social media
she says pua wasn't designed to last
forever this program is going to end in
september and so we're trying to get
everybody prepared
now back out here live it is important
to keep those records because deter
could
ask for those again this all starts this
weekend may 2nd
reporting live near sahara indicator
this evening joe mohler 8 news now